in his first foray into the u.s chess
championship john burke has won his game
john i know you are happy about winning
the game but you must not be too
thrilled about the fact that at some
point you were
losing the game yeah i realized after f6
like after a few seconds that if he just
inverted the move order um then i'm
basically busted because i don't have
queen d6 right so yeah i guess we could
show like a bf4 we'll show it on we have
a screen
right in front there for you to take a
look at
and we were discussing this position
indeed f6 yeah so he basically just has
to take on v5 first and that the point
is
i can't ever take with a pawn because he
has e takes f6
um i thought rook f6 knight takes g4
and the ship takes c4 where it takes a7
is the point
and queen a3 check and rick takes e7
and it's lost
yep
so
yeah and the difference between what he
did is if he took ab5 first like right
here and i take c takes like in the game
then simply queen a3 and i don't have
queen d6
so
yeah i really didn't know what i was
going to do i was panicking a little you
were sitting there like oh no yeah of
course but he was thinking a long time
and like
i don't know i thought that
if that's the sort of idea if you see it
you just play it so i got a little bit
of hope because he was burning a lot of
time
and i don't know if you saw that idea
and just played the wrong move order or
what happened but basically that time
cost him in the end cause
george like moved 40 he started um
making mistakes really panicking indeed
uh getting getting a win like this one
has got to breed some
some some wind into your sails feeling
like wow i could have just been dead
of course and now suddenly it's a full
point yeah well i'm glad at least i won
one game this tournament that there's
one one goal um done but yeah in general
i was just trying to
stay calm and play well i mean normally
in first rounds
shaky anyway it takes me a few rounds to
get into form and especially first time
playing here i was definitely a little
nervous so after f6 i was kicking myself
like how could i
blow the game so stupidly in the very
first round but yeah i'm very relieved
all right well that's a great point
we all dream about playing in a u.s
championship playing in the national
championship
when you won
last year to know you were going to win
to play now
did you have that full excitement like
i'm going to achieve a boyhood dream
and then feel like oh but i am going to
have to play these guys
yeah yeah both i guess of course a mix
of both it was kind of odd because like
i qualified a year ago so like at first
i thought it would be in april of this
year but because of kofi obviously
everything got moved around so it's very
rare that like you're anticipating a
tournament for a whole year so i guess i
had a lot of time to think about it and
prepare and get ready but yeah as you
said it's a mix of both of course i'm so
excited to be here i wouldn't trade the
experience for anything but it's a
little nerve-wracking you know having to
play these these top players but i'm up
for the challenge i think indeed we're
up for the challenge survive this one
good luck
and also a good play in the rest of your
games thanks yes indeed john